hey I'm Dan Perrault and these are 10
reasons to see Deadpool number 10 hard
our action the Deadpool action is so
graphic it got banned in China so for
all your responsible parents out there
it might not be the best film to take
your kids to but for all you
irresponsible parents go right ahead
your kids will love it
number 9 the twisted humor as the
trailer show us this will be one of the
most quotable offensive movies ever with
lines like you look like Freddy Krueger
just topographical map of Utah gets my
mom every time number eight they've been
working on this for a long time Ryan
Reynolds was first attached to play
Deadpool in 2004 shortly after starring
as that other Marvel character in blade
Trinity but let's not talk about that
since then Reynolds has been determined
to deliver a Deadpool that will satisfy
the fans number 7 New Mutants Deadpool
takes place in the same universe as the
other x-men films including that first
film of Deadpool x-men origins Wolverine
let's not talk about that either this
movie will introduce new x-men
characters like negasonic teenage
warhead and the new mutant villain angel
dust number 6
no fourth-wall this movie doesn't just
break the fourth wall it demolishes it
Deadpool will address the audience
directly and probably make fun of other
superhero movies as we see in the first
trailer Deadpool not so subtly makes fun
of Reynolds other superhero flop Green
Lantern let's just pretend Ryan Reynolds
didn't do superhero film number five
Colossus
one of the most powerful mutants from
the previous x-men films is back it's
the same characters before but with a
new actor and a buffer look that's a
little closer to the Colossus from the
comics number four Ryan Reynolds but do
I need elaborate number three it's
faithful to the comics at comic-con Ryan
Reynolds told Hall H it's the most
faithful adaptation of a comic book to a
movie he's ever seen the Deadpool team
is so confident they got this right they
tweeted a page from the script along
with written notes by Deadpool that we
probably shouldn't show you number two
it's the perfect date movie not really
but that's what some people will think
when they see the trick billboards
promoting Deadpool as a rom-com and
Deadpool does open on Valentine's Day
weekend so for all you guys out there
trying to make it a Deadpool date good
luck it's not
problem with me because cuz I don't have
a girlfriend yeah
number one the Stan Lee cameo x-men
co-creators Stan Lee is making another
Marvel cameo in this film and I won't
tell you what the Cameo is but it's
awesome so I want to tell you but I
won't I won't tell you but I want to
tell you it's really bad I want to tell
you I can't I will tell you okay so he's
it and and it's just hilarious me it was
worth the price of admission thank you
for listening and that's ten reasons to
see Deadpool I'm Dan Perrault check out
Deadpool in theaters February 12
you